[Music]
hello i'm grandma students
and this is a game of the week where
you will hear about a young russian
grand master
taking the total steel the chesapeake
chess
with a vengeance in fact we're going to
start with his
very first big success beating the world
champion himself so let's take a look
so this game is
yesi panko playing e4
versus carlsen which by in itself is a
big surprise
because yesi panko most of his young
career
would close with d4 and c4 instead of
the open e4
now he did play e4 earlier on against
grandelios
which actually follow the same pattern
that we're going to take a look at
but it's still an interesting thing to
mention that
jessipenko would decide to do a little
switch around
against carlson himself e4
c5 knight f3
d6 d4 takes
takes knight f6 a6
so carlson shows his clear intentions of
trying to
win this game at all costs and
it actually backfires but
not necessarily a bad choice because one
of the lowest rated player it was and is
as
yesipenko so if you're not trying
against the lowest rated
you can really hardly try to get first
place
bishop e2 and here instead
of playing e5 which happened in the
grand alias game
here carlson goes for e6
more like in the style of his former
coach
gary kasparov gary kasparov famously won
many many games with the chevening again
including
the most important game of all time
especially for
kasparov against karpov and the last
round game which
he won with the black pieces e6
bishop e3 bishop e7 and here comes
really the shocker the move
g4 which has been played
multiple times before but
probably cause and did not anticipate
yesipanko
go that aggressive against him
and i believe this might have came as a
shock
that yasibenko didn't just come up to
play a normal cheveningen which would
have been
f4 castles castles
knight c6 a4 rook e8
king h1 rook b8 and this is the typical
typical main line
very well known played by
generations through the 70s 80s and 90s
and this is still considered to be very
much playable for black
and in fact the carp of kasparov
game is also this type of cheveningen
structure
so instead of like this slowpoke play
with f4 castle on a4 yes ibanko
immediately launches
at carlson which is something
that they rarely do against
magnus and that actually was a very very
smart choice
by sc yesipanko's team deciding that it
is time to be
more of an attacking like playing more
of an attacking
chess in fact nakamura kind of gave the
interview
himself when he was playing in the
magnus tour that he noticed whenever
magnus is under some kind of attack
he's not as confident defending
as he is like sort of playing
strategic positions b5
g5 knight d7 a3
and i really like this move a3
kind of make sure and kind of
offers um carlson to take that bait
that bait pawn on g5 and also stops any
sort of ideas of b5 b4
which in turn would weaken the spawn on
e4
and that could become kind of
uncomfortable
a3 and carlson makes a calculated risk
which i think sort of backfires in this
case
because normally he likes taking risks
and tries to go for broke
when he sort of out of shape and he was
sort of out of shape
before this game as well so he's trying
to win somehow so here taking the pawn
makes sense from a positional standpoint
or lack more like a tournament stand
point of view
however a better choice would have been
to go bishop b7
queen d2 knight c5 f3 and knight
bd7 kind of getting into this
typical sicilian positions or even
knight c6
which might be slightly worse for black
but
it really isn't as dangerous as taking
the pawn
taken upon is sort of gambling which
sounds
sort of paradoxical you'd assume that
taking on g5
is a gamble for white but in fact it's
more of a gamble for black
as there'll be heavy attack on this king
and the pawns on the king's side
while black still have yet to get
his pieces out queen d2 queen e2 is a
strong move
so once white gives up the pawn he goes
over for
quick development and sort of tries to
gain time
even if there's any exchange he's sort
of improving his pieces
queen takes c3 and not only does the
queen
put this king in an x-ray but after long
castles
there is this d6 pawn weakness that can
be
kind of annoyed and very hard to defend
as the bishop on e7 is missing and which
is the key
defender in these type of positions
again rook
queen h4 that is not such a great move
because it again it takes away some
important squares
but it doesn't really help with
development and still leaves the d6 and
g7 pawns
sort of loose queen h4 was played
rook g1 very straight up play
by yesi panko he is not afraid
to play some wild attacking chess
g6 long castles
queen e7 f4
very straightforward and in this sense
it's
probably not a bad choice but yes the
whole opening was a great
idea especially because
white's plan is very very very on point
you just need to run it down with f4 f5
and if you manage to break through then
you know black might just be completely
lost without much of a fight
castling short would be a bit too much
as it would allow f5
and if e takes there's knight d5 as well
or even bishop f3
but not to mention knight f5 which is
actually winning on the spot
bishop b7 king b1
a typical move not always the best
sometimes it's better to go
full throttle attacking on the king side
however if white would try to play f5 it
would
give away this e5 square which could
become
quite important so king mi1 is a good
waiting move
sort of yesipanko is wondering what
carlson is up to next if castles again
f5 is an idea but h4h5 also gains in
strength
as the king has already committed itself
on this side of the board
so here kind of disliking his position
calls and plays the somewhat
unconventional unusual
knight c6 which turns out to be a quite
a bit of a mistake
and a miscalculation still here black
should have gone knight c5
and possibly go for something like
knight b d7
and get this typical setup which is not
that easy
to break through thank you and just
gives a fantastic fantastic um
chance for black to hold it's not that
black is not where it's probably still
worse
however those pieces
do coordinate much much better in this
case knight c6
just doesn't look right and it's not the
usual setup
as i mentioned knight c5 knight bd7 is
what you should be
looking for and this actually runs into
knight takes cb5
a very strong move sort of setting up
this idea which happens in the game
queen c3 hitting both the bishop and
the rook the same time and i am very
confident
that carlson missed this idea
castles queen takes c6 now when i was
watching this
online and looking of what was going to
happen in this game
many of the quebecers said that black is
going to
go down in a couple of moves but
probably they're not
familiar of the level of tenacity
of super grand master chess super grand
masters don't give up and they try
till the last moment to fight it back
and here if carlson would have just a
little bit better position
he might have like a real
chance to gamble his way back to the
game but this is just
not good enough anymore d5 is still a
very creative choice
by carlson he is sort of saying this
queen on c6
is a little bit uncomfortable and
you still have to be accurate to stay
afloat
he takes rook fc8
and here comes the point that i'm making
it's never too late to mess up a good
position in the sicilian
d6 here was a strong move by yesi panko
but if you take on b5 go here
queen c6 rook takes b2 king takes b2
check here queen a1 and it is a game
over
not for black but for white and this is
what makes
the sicilians so appealing even if you
have a position that is objectively very
close to lost
you get some chances to fight
on as gary kasparov put it
you can still go kicking and screaming
before you go down
now here in this case yes panko was
very vigilant and stopped this idea
if you take then d take c7 and with that
e pawn
on the seventh this is completely losing
so black has to go queen d8 defend the
knight
queen takes b5 again fearless move and
these are kind of the moves
that shows the real talent of the
russian grandmaster he's not afraid
to open up his own queen side
because he knows that there's just too
many pawns there and with these pieces
being
all tucked away on the eighth and seven
that shouldn't be enough
for a win for black or like a big attack
queen c4 still very careful
trying to be around the king who takes
c3 queen c7 and queen c7 actually
sort of realizes that the game is by no
means over
there's still some accurate moves
that are required between c7 just make
sure there
are no queen b6 ideas and then
black would still try to
get some play there queen e8
now black i don't think is really having
enough play
but yes he panko's next move is a class
act by in itself
he realizes that the rook and bishop is
actually doing all right this rook
is supporting the d-pawn the queen is
sort of paralyzing the queen and the
knight
so the only thing left is to get rid of
this rook on b8 and that rook on a3
therefore he goes rogue g5 sort of
involving this rook
via the fifth blocking of the bh rook
and that will definitely mean that
white is on top and
by now this is getting close to decisive
advantage
before the computers would already say
that this is
a decisive advantage but from a human
perspective and standpoint this is still
not yet
over with this maneuver of rook g5 rook
b5
it's getting more and more clear that
it's game over
okay four row k5
exchanging off this rook also not
allowing the doubling on the a
file rook b4
b3 and not
really afraid of any of those threats
the king
would walk away after any sort of
sacrifices
and with no bishop on the h8
a1 diagonal this actually
is a decent position for white
and basically winning rook
b7 queen c3 queen d8
bishop f3 but notice whenever yesi panko
andrei sipenko has
the momentum to over defend his pieces
he does so
rook b4 b4 the queen could arrive to b6
queen 67 shows up on the board and the
idea
of bishop c6 again is coming
queen f6 rook a8
now again some people would not really
like
this way of playing but actually it
makes a lot of sense
you're a human you try to exchange
pieces
for a bit more of a clarity and just
making sure that there
are no tricks involved rook takes
bishop takes queen f5 king b2
rook b5 queen takes d7 and
as these pieces the rook on b5 and the
queen on f5
got a little bit more discoordinated he
decides to capture the piece
anyways rook c5 rook c1
over defending takes check
and d7 and it is a game over
so quite a nice win by esc
panko and
not such a good game for
carlson but when someone plays a
fantastic game it is quite normal
to not be able to put up
that much resistance also carlson wasn't
in a great shape
before the game now this is not
the last game i want to show i do want
to show
another game where yasipanko
continues on with his way of playing and
continues on
to play fantastic chess
now if you're new to competitive chess
winning a game with white and them
facing a super grand master
the next day is not the easiest task in
fact he faced feroza the other prodigy
with the black pieces he comfortably
held which
is actually just as uh of a big
of an achievement as beating calzon
because
believe me when you beat a strong player
or a world champion at it that
you do feel depleted and sort of empty
so going on empty but the next game is
not that
easy now that game is not that exciting
so we're gonna skip on that one
i believe we are going to take a look
at the other game between yesi panko and
anton giharo anton
um anton giharo and he
is a big talent of spain
but it seems that yasi panko for the
time and time being he is unstoppable
so let's take a look again goes for e4
um never change the winning team that
could be
yesipanko's motto um this game will be
actually a bit more fighting as anton
guiharro
probably was very conscious that he is
playing someone
in shape or in form um he responds with
e5
instead of causing c5
going from our for a more solid
positional
game instead of a tactical one which
might not have been a bad choice in
general
um but again just look how
yes panko comfortably and slowly
outplays anton guiharro
david even though he
already beat because uh he didn't play
kasparov but he did beat kazan
and drew firoja and that will mean
after this game he is two and a half
points out of three which
is a champion record knight f3
knight c6 bishop b5 now i know
some people started playing bishop c4
but the big boy move is still bishop b5
the spanish has always been the best
and most challenging for black a6 bishop
a4
knight f6 castle bishop e7
d3 and d3 again kind of signals
that yes panko is here to fight
now he could also go rookie one but then
we might
get into very theoretical uh territory
with c3nd5 and marshall gambit
which has been played in many many
matches including the famous
kramnik laco match so d3 which is a bit
more of a solid choice over defending
the pawn b5 bishop b3
d6 bishop d2 and bishop d2
looks like a clumsy move but it's kind
of just trying to stop these knight a5
ideas of
trapping the bishop on b3
in fact this has been created
by alexander grishoek himself
and been championed by
mr fabiano caruana 2
in fact won a very important game in
2018
versus levan aronyan which actually
helped him
qualify for the world championship match
bishop g4 sort of
putting pressure as these pieces are a
little bit scattered
but why does happy to play c3 because
white's argument is that this bishop on
g4 is not
that useful over there bishop h5
rookie 1 knight a5 bishop c2
c5 h3 castles
bishop c1 all these moves seem a little
bit odd and they are but the whole point
was
to sort of lure that bishop to h5
and that possibly can become a target in
a couple of moves like knight d2 knight
f1 knight g3 white is going to gain that
time
back and then he can do the classical d4
breaks which are well
very well known in the spanish knight c6
anton quijaro is not interested in that
happening
too early knight d2 and d5
and you can sense that both players came
out to play they're trying to take the
center as quickly as they can
d5 is actually a very combative move he
is trying to take over
not f1 and knight f1 is a cheeky little
move by andre
yessi panko he's actually saying hey if
you want
we can play this end game you'll be
slightly worse
but maybe it's tenable but
i guess in some ways this bluff does
work out as
anton quijaro is not interested in
salvaging half a point he's more
interested in a fighting game so he goes
for d4
which is again completely legitimate and
a good way of playing
but just shows how
exciting this started steel tournament
is because all of the players are aiming
for fighting chess
and not just meager draws knight g3
bishop g6 obviously taking on f3 would
be a mistake
because not only would it give a bishop
pair for white
white might even go knight f5 later on
bishop g6 bishop d2
so at the moment we could still state
that
black is more or less fine has like a
two to one advantage in the center
but it's a closed position so it is not
as important now of course if takes
then white could even consider taking
with the bishop but naturally you would
want to take
towards the center with the b-pawn and
that would give you
a decent chance in this scenario
rook c8 rook c1 so this
is actually the tense moment nobody
really knows who's better
one of the concerns for black is this
bishop as we already talked about
multiple times already on the other hand
white is a lacking with space so
for white the biggest issue is not
that there are any targets in black's
position but if there is a breakthrough
or not
possibly something like a4 a6 b5 could
be an idea or maybe
opening up with b4 although there's a
lot of pieces defending those squares
rookie 8 queen e2 bishop f8
queen f1 somewhat of a mysterious move
but probably he's just trying to
do a 960 chess removing the queen
from trouble and sort of creating
this idea of rook d1
thinking that that rook will be much
much more useful over there rook there
actually goes the other way around queen
d7
some of these moves are a little bit
cryptic queen d6 queen d7 feels like
a waiting move and not really awe
inspiring
but now that h4 is awe-inspiring as
yesepenko is going after that outpost
and if he gets it
then there'll be some positional
pressure on
black queen d8 knight f5
knight d7 so anton guijaro is trying to
play around it might even do
f6 and bishop f7 trying to get this
bishop back into the game and maybe go
for c4
queen e2 and here decides not to do it
possibly because of this ideas of h4h5
and with some pressure on that king
even the idea of going queen g4 could be
nasty
as bishop f7 would run into knight h6
check and knight f7
wins the piece and the queen
so probably for that reason or he goes
the
other way knight f5 knight d7
queen e2 queen f6
he doesn't go that direction even if you
go
f6 here white can go queen g4 and that
is very uncomfortable
in f6 rook c1 so there's a lot of shadow
boxing going on in this game
which is somewhat more rare these days
but
was one of the big way of playing chess
especially in the late 80s
and the early 2000s they like playing
these
slow moving games so you see panko is
sort of getting that
from those books knight b6
and he plays the somewhat surprising
move c4
not much an attacking move but stopping
the idea
of c4 which he might feel is just going
to be
very annoying to face so instead he
plays c4 himself
kind of making those b6 and c6 knights
look
a little bit offsides and he might argue
that in the long run he could go for
rook f1 g3 f4
somewhat of a king's indian style which
sort of reminds me of fabiano corona's
game
that was played not long ago a couple of
days ago versus donchenko where
actually the king's indian they succeed
so takes
takes rook b8
g3 preparing f4
he might not play f4 immediately he
might do it a bit later
knight b1 knight b4 bishop b1
knight c8 so black realizes that these
knights are a little bit clumsy
santon giharo is trying to remaneuver
that knight to d6
and even though this looks very
comfortable for black
it doesn't really provide like an easy
plan
for black to follow anytime you would
push the pawn that become a weakness and
if you don't push it then what is the
extra advantage of this d-pawn
as it can easily be blockaded later on
in the game
on the other hand white has a simple
simple plan of either going
rook f1 f4 or maybe even knight for an
h5
so it's something that humans would
consider
an easier position to play as white and
a tougher one for black
now computer might say this is
completely fine for the black player but
in reality this might be just a good
practical choice for white
knight takes g6 taking the bishop
knight h4 now this actually is an
interesting choice because
we definitely have a close position here
but i guess yesipenko is sort of
anticipating
that in the long run either they'll be
h4h5 or f4
and then the the position will open up
queen e6 king g2 so
clearly yes panko is playing for long
term plans knight d6
this knight isn't involved in the game
so goes knight f3
bishop e7 a3
knight c6 b4 and guess what that is why
it is important to know
that if you have the bishop pair you're
supposed to open up the position
so once you know that this maneuver of
a4
a3 b4 does make a lot of sense and if
that succeeds y does get a big advantage
and indeed this works so white is
getting the advantage he's been dreaming
of
c5 it takes b4 and again this is sort of
the new meta of chess you are trying to
get
some fighting positions and you try to
outsmart your opponent
and clearly this is what is happening in
this game yesipenko did not get
necessarily an advantage in the opening
but he got a position that was much more
comfortable for him to
play around with and anton giharo
has been a bit more shaky in deciding on
a plan
and now these knights look somewhat
stable
but if you look more deeply that a pawn
will become a big target
bishop f6 bishop d3 and now look how the
situation has changed
the position is opening up the bishop is
going to arrive
on c4 press on f7 and there is a good
chance of doubling on the a
file knight c3
so anton quijaro realizes the turn of
events and tries to pull the brakes
but it is actually a little bit too late
now
bishop takes c3 dc bishop c4
not even taking the c pawn yet first
activating the bishop
and then looking around whether to take
or not
and he does take rook takes b4
bishop d5 knight d4 queen takes a6
and again it seems like uh white
triumphed
from a positional standpoint of u this
bishop
is dominating the board targeting the f7
pawn
and will support this c palm pushes
even if you take on f3 king takes f3
the king will have enough time to walk
back that pawn
is just too fast and with the bishop
closed in like that
it's very unlikely that black is going
to survive this game
queen c7 knight takes rook takes c2
so yes benko knows that with
this closed in bishop that's not really
a big threat
in fact it is much better for him to
exchange and get the opposite colored
bishop middle game because he gets this
extra option of f4e5
sort of pushing antongiharo even more
off the board g5 a very strong move by
anton guiharo
making sure there are no breaks with f4
but that's not going to be enough
queen d3 bishop e5
or k1 and some of the modern talents
who are dominating referring here to
yesipanko occasionally firuja
they kind of feel where their pieces
belong
or where to put them if they want to
activate them now rook a1 is a
clearly clearly the best move here
because if the rook can arrive on a7 the
f7 pawn is going to fall prey
in the long run and also combined with
that c6 pawn push
that'd be just too many threats to
handle for the spaniard
queen e7 rook a6
rook f8 c6 and again this is kind of the
position where you'd feel that
yes maybe some hopes of holding with
black
but practically this is lost as black
has to make
too many accurate moves to survive
also there's just too many targets like
i talked about the f7 pawn already
this rook is optimally placed supporting
the c
pawn but even the g pawn is weak and the
king will be facing certain
threats rook b8 rook ca2
so just as i said he pushed the pawn got
all his rooks on the a file and now
black is
basically paralyzed rook bc8
rook a7 rook c7 rook b7
again yes panko is making sure
that black cannot move and clearly black
has
no way of moving around
g6 queen d2 rook fc8
takes takes and here comes the final
assault on the black king h4
chasing that pawn away if it doesn't
move white can just take
and that's more than enough pawns for
white to win
another g takes h4 queen h6
shows up on the board and here black
resigned rightfully so
because not only does he have to face
with business threat of
rook a8 and checkmate but there is this
big threat
of queen takes a g6 kind of
dominating the position and it's just
game
over and that is what i wanted
to show fantastic fantastic games
from yesi panko and with a couple of
rounds left he's
actually only a half a point behind
the leader and he is going to
have a shot at becoming
the champion of tata steel a first
champion
who would become a champion as a wild
card
which would be something special thank
you for watching
and good night
you